i was anointed to be the guy  ever since i was little  leader leader learn how to be a leader i  had no idea what leadership meant  until i was in the uh  it's in the four seasons on doheny one  day and a guy gave me a book by john c  maxwell  and it just talked about leadership  and i read that book and i was like oh  my god  so i just started you know applying  those certain things and you know i was  shacking up a little things but as the  leader  it's my job to go upstairs and be like  hey  you got me and kobe they're saying we're  the best but yeah  we've been getting swept every year  horace grant is you know i talked to  horace myself he said he's ready to come  so  can we make a move to get not i wouldn't  go upstairs go get me horace graham i'm  leaving i'm like hey we need like we'd  sit down and have conversations and  jerry west was the best guy to have a  conversation with because he hated  losing